hello and welcome to this video
Forgotten prophecies my opponent and we
could have began again well not not very
not very scared yeah let's say yeah
white is fighting for equality him and
oftentimes not very successfully yeah 93
a form the Vienna game with f4 it's um
yeah it's mostly a trick opening
honestly if black can knows knows his
stuff white is just going to be yeah in
not good shape so what's going on here
if I take D - is that even a playable
move we should be 39222 C takes d4
Knight 64 Queen Shaq mmm yes sir covered
because we should be 5 ok if I take on
d4 this Knight takes e4 that doesn't
work
I mean it's still not bad right doing
this I mean I'm not winning immediately
but meets the Queen age for Queen d4
it's a bit lucky for him that that he
has that it should be five at the end I
don't think it was pre-planned okay so
if I check him it's not yeah let's just
do this I'm taking too long and whites
position is not good anyway
almost no matter what I do I just tend
to try to refute those bad lines I mean
I really wanted to kill them immediately
if they play if they play a bad openings
but that sometimes not very practical
so chick cannot so just play Bishop d7
Bishop g4 is also not bad let's do this
prevent long castles right I totally
forgot that you can take on c6 hey we
really have to pay attention to some
bathing things what am I doing here
yeah okay
I like that that's just amazing I just
plugged it on c6 yeah that's really bad
especially because the position was
already pretty bad for white I mean that
opening is just completely bad anyway
mom yeah blunder c6 this is this is
absolutely amazing
Queen b6 or whatever everything was fine
yeah it's just it's just unfortunately
completely lost you cannot even suppose
many problems
it's exchanged down and no no particular
idea that you can go for
what what a weird thing
just didn't pay attention I guess no
very very hard decision
no it's very easy for white to convert
this don't have any particular threat or
active idea just try to be a bit quicker
and and hope that he makes some some
mistake which is probably not going to
happen the taking if I that's not very
scary
you know I mean is he's doing quite a
bit of things that are not great but the
position is just too bad even with bad
play you cannot screw it up really
Americans you can check and finish admit
it is too lost look to a teenager a
checkmate
doesn't see it okay rubbing it in
what are they okay I made a move there I
just wanted to put it back I'm not going
to rematch no and this is just totally
terrible what did I do that I just had a
total blackout I mean I was pretty much
maybe not taking it serious anymore this
whole line is already pretty terrible
for what you can maybe equalize if you
be super precise but this is yeah okay
well it was quite funny I mean I cannot
win the police right away and because of
Bishop b5 but okay knight c6 any normal
movie gives black a pretty clear
advantage I think 96 I have the bishop a
is called weaknesses all over the place
is just terrible and now some normal
move even cancelling is good yeah I mean
you cannot grab this the problem was
that I blunder the full exchange the
ship g4 is just pretty much inexplicable
if I just cancel what's position is
terrible just terrible what are you
doing you you don't have good place for
your king what is what is the engine
suggestion 96b takes who could be eight
or something I really really am
surprised that it just on 0.5 I mean it
looks like white is in total disarray
God everything is open here yeah I kind
of Bishop g4 is just a complete complete
brain failure yeah it's just totally
lost you you cannot do anything many
could have checkmated me quicker but it
just just totally lost yeah there was
there was there that was made of course
you create needs to checkmate mate okay
yeah but I couldn't couldn't do well
Queenie five yeah just going to be a
lost ending and then it's funny I wanted
to put it back but it put it but the
police quick put it on the wrong I don't
know I don't know what happened damn I
have no idea what was what was I doing
with when I played Bishop g4 I mean I
didn't quite take it seriously anymore
that that I know but still Bishop g4 is
how to dig hard to explain
yeah maybe it's kind of one thing where
you make the second move from first that
you yet you think about and then you you
make it and don't really recognize oh
wait I had to cover the cover the thing
first anyway okay thanks for watching